[Music]
sad news out of that camp marfan mike
died over the weekend
and he is singing from heaven oh my
goodness
yeah very sad news i was a big marfan
mike fan big advocate of him being on
the show becoming part of the whack pack
i see high-pitched eric is calling in
because he's upset about marfan mike
he's got some nerve really he hated him
what i remember of your history with
marfan mike he was mean to you in high
school marfan
bullied you which was an amazing story
because the two of you should have
formed your own little whack pack in
high school but
um you saw him as a bit of a bully i
guess and marfan said that's ridiculous
well listen his dream was to come on
your show
and we inducted him into the whack pack
well i got to stop you there we didn't
you vote against him yes i did
but after it came down to that him and i
made up i want to say
uh rest in peace morphine mike you'll be
missed by
not you but not you right by everyone
else yes but no but no by me listen the
weapon's in the back there's a brother
and a sister all right i remember when i
uh swore in marfan during the conclave
if you remember that show there was a
big conclave where we had every whack
pack member vote on whether marfan would
make it in and uh
deciding vote was i even remember that i
can play it for you here you go here's
the guy who decided no i do believe
that eric
would you [ __ ] just tell us what's on
your mind
[Laughter]
right asian feet i mean this [ __ ] guy
go ahead
they
are from my
you are more useless than
[Music]
ever think he should have a chance to
prove him
and i know that
you want him in
and therefore
the combination
puts him into the way whoa
when he called and he was diamond mike
we knew we needed a better name
it should be marfan
marfan mike nice fred marfan mike yeah
fred's good at torturing people abraham
lincoln was allegedly a sufferer of this
scene
he sounded like this i had the honor of
swearing um marfan mike into the
whack pack
i
that i will faithfully execute my duties
as a member of the wack pack
uh
faithfully
my
um what's in wendy's diaper
and will to the best of my disabilities
with that you are now a made member of
the black pack
marfan was so happy he just was dead
excited yes he loved the idea marfan
brought his dad down
his dad came in and hugged him it was
beautiful
we lost a wonderful addition to the
black pack
i want to say may he rest in peace and
he will be missed